are you hot for
anyone Lisa does he have more of a
basketball bot or a football B he
doesn't play
sports my tend is grave I talk to him I
wish I was with
you that's really weird
[Music]
Lisa you hear that I'm sure it's the
girl next door she's very
odd your
hand I can't believe you're here do you
like music I have the Cure oh not that
kind of cure they can't make you better
I mean they can but like emotionally no
don't cry your tears smell so
bad send it back you need friend no I
love it it's not really my
[Music]
style when you're in doubt L looks good
she could probably even do pageants if
she had
Congeniality your daughter has a little
psycho I open my glorious home to an
ungrateful
[Applause]
little
tell I want to help you but Taffy says
it's a waste of time to try and fix a BL
it's better just accept a guy's father
oh that's so
cute I have an idea there are bad people
out there come on Lisa it'll feel
good that hand was going to do terrible
things you are being admitted impatient
lock down I the
world all the clink for life or the
electric chair but I don't want to die a
virgin you know anything about The
Disappearance of a
student I'm not making any more
comments you can talk to my laer really
hope this goth phase in soon you need a
friend